bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors c'est un
accord commercial qui serait le plus
important du monde en termes de produit
intérieur brut on l'a dit selon des
analystes à ce que vous partagez cette
analyse bonjour et c'est un plaisir de
vous retrouver sur ses comptes et france
alors et un accord commercial faut
évidemment le mesurer vous avez raison
de dire qu'en termes de pib on a là une
zone qui est au groupe un pib colossal
s'allumant les accords commerciaux se
sont aussi pas comptés simplement
surface des économies mais plutôt la
surface des changes le commerce
moi j'aimerais appeler parce qu'à
demander en quoi c'est important mais
j'aimerais rappeler quelques chiffres
le commerce bilatéral entre la chine et
la z c'est à peu près 650 milliards de
dollars en tout cas si on projet sur
l'année 2020 ce qui s'est passé sur les
trois premier trimestres si on prend
évidemment c'est pas simplement au
niveau de la chine l'asian si on prend
par exemple le commerce bilatéral entre
le japon et la zea nez est à peu près
150 milliards entre le japon et la chine
qui sont des cosignataires des 200
milliards etc
il faudrait regarder l'ensemble mais on
culmine à 1 à 1000 milliards ou à peu
près rien que le commerce intra union
européenne sans compter sans compter oui
évidemment on est à 3000 milliards soit
3 fois plus vous voyez donc en termes
d'intégration des économies
je dirais c'est à la fois un pas majeur
parce que ça faisait huit ans qu'il y
avait cette négociation mais ça n'est
qu'un premier pas donc c'est peut-être
une très grande zone économique mais
c'est une zone qui n'est pas si intégré
que ça qui est en voie d'intégration
alors cet accord on dit aussi qu'il
pourrait servir les ambitions
géopolitiques de la chine qu'en est il
réellement
oui à tout peut servir les ambitions
géopolitiques de la chine à savoir si
elle si elle en a vraiment russie la
chine cède à la chinoise d'un papier
d'un autre et c'est rare ce que font à
peu près toutes les puissances moi
j'observe une chose c'est que cet accord
a mis huit ans à être négociées
d'ailleurs il avait les premières
négociations avaient lieu au sommet de
l'asie où il se trouve que j'étais à ce
moment-là obama était venu est en effet
il y avait un grand espoir que
l'amérique
enfin ce parti aujourd'hui la main
n'en fait pas partie je pense qu'il ne
faut pas sûr lire ou sur interpréter le
fait que l'amérique ne fasse pas partie
déjà à l'époque déjà allé à 8 ans on se
rendait compte que en termes de
spécialisation différencier les
avantages comparatifs de l'amérique et
les avantages comparatifs de la zone à 0
de manière générale n'était pas
tellement complémentaires a renchéri une
complémentarité plus forte
déjà à l'époque entre laser et la chine
et je veux dire il a fallu huit ans pour
que la chine signent cet accord ça c'est
la première chose deuxième chose des
points de vue de l'amérique
beaucoup d'entreprises américaines sont
déjà présentes multinationales sont
présentes américaines sont présentes à
la fois en chine et à la fois au sein de
l'asian donc une partie du commerce
chine
asian par exemple qui va être porté par
cet accord au japon asian qui sera aussi
le fruit de transferts intra firme
américaine dans sa avantage de toute
façon les firmes américaines voilà c'est
1 1 c'est un accord très important
d'intégration mais je ne pense pas qu'il
faille sur lire un retrait de l'amérique
en tout cas pas du capitalisme numérique
n est pas d entreprise et des
multinationales américaines qui sont
très présentes au coeur de cet accord
que c'est un accord important matière
d'intégration mais justement on sait qu
aussi beaucoup de nations dans cette
région cette partie du monde sont très
attachés à leur souveraineté économique
c'est le cas par exemple de dollars donc
est ce que c'est un outil finalement qui
peut être efficace en matière
d'intégration économique alors deux
choses rien n'est pas ne fait pas partie
de l'accord - au moment où on y
reviendra
mais y compris pour des pays qui font
partie de l'accord je pense qu'il faut
bien voir japon par exemple ou même des
pays laser je pense qu'il faut voir des
choses je pense qu' une partie des
éléments qu'il ya trois ya trois aspects
qui font de cette il ya un premièrement
il simplification des accords vous avez
la vingtaine de pays
ça faisait à peu près il y avait à peu
près 300 accords bilatéraux dont il
avait signé une espèce des spécialistes
appelés c'est une espèce de spaghetti le
bol de nouilles qui est un peu simplifié
par un accord multilatéral
ça c'est la première neige la deuxième
raison est un peu plus politique donc
donc en fait on part déjà d'accord
commerce qui existait on part comparé
d'une base prise
deuxième point il ya en effet un message
politique qui consiste à dire nous
sommes une zone de croissance nous la
sinn ce niveau de croissance et nous
croyons dans elia j'allais dire un
troisième point qui est dans l'arrière
pensée de tous les dirigeants de la zone
et vous aviez raison de mentionner
chaque pays est très soucieux de son
indépendance de sa souveraineté
économique et chacun sait qu'il ya
encore énormément j'allais dire réserve
énormément de klose ne serait ce que
pour prendre le cas d'accord latéral
interne à cet accord mutuel des terrains
entre le japon et chili à plus de 1300
pages de clauses qui restent à discuter
donc on a signé n'a signé en marge d'un
accord d'un sommet virtuel donc en fait
les équipes n'ont pas pu négocier je
crois que c'est un message mais je crois
qu'il ya énormément de travail à faire
au dernier point très rapidement vous
mentionnez l'inde et bien l'inde a
toujours été très attentive à se
rapprocher de la gmv tout aussi
attentifs à ne pas trop dépendre des
importations chinoises et ses
partenaires de l'asian surtout thaci
attentifs à ça donc si l'un ne devait
pas rejoindre le rct je pense qu'on peut
imaginer un rapprochement 1 à 0 merci
beaucoup à vous joël ruiz rappelle que
vous êtes économiste à ses rêves
présidentiels